alors à parler de jean luc mélenchon
dans luc mélenchon qui est l'objet de
votre baromètre mensuel au dos que ça
pour les chaînes parlementaires et la
presse régionale et donc analyse de
l'image de jean luc mélenchon avec ça
les pattes un mode très laid pas très
bonne avec un chiffre qui est instructif
d'entrée les deux tiers des français ont
une mauvaise opinion de jean luc
mélenchon est donc le tiers restant à
une bonne image du candidat de la france
insoumise alors est ce qui est
intéressant c'est de regarder
l'évolution de l'image de jean luc
mélenchon ces dernières années en août
2016 il était et bien à 39% d'opinions
positives de la part des français en
2017 il était même est bien l'homme
politique préféré des français c'est
l'année de la présidentielle où il est
arrivé aux portes du second tour et à
partir du quinquennat d'emmanuel macro
et bien sa cote elle a dégringolé pour
arriver en septembre
2019 moment la fameuse perquisition par
la police judiciaire perquisition du
siège de la france insoumise avec cette
altercation avec les policiers
et là à l'époque et bien jean luc
mélenchon était à 28% d'opinions
positives depuis il a récupéré quelques
points de popularité mais il n'est pas à
son niveau de 2010 est cette altercation
et coûte cher ce quinquennat d'emmanuel
macau en terme d'image il coûte cher oui
sur sur le sur le long terme est
effectivement comme vous le dise il a
quand même réussi à corriger la ces
derniers mois a corrigé sa son image et
il progresse il est sur une vraie
dynamique quand même sur sur le premier
tour il est passé deux environ 10 % y
stagnent et aux alentours des 10% voire
un peu moins jusqu'à la mi février hélas
ces dernières semaines il progresse il
approche les 15% il n'est pas impossible
qu'il figure au second tour si marine le
pen
dépasse tout juste les 16 ou 17 % lui
peut encore aller gratter deux ou trois
points auprès des électeurs de gauche
donc c'est une un vrai potentiel pour
lui d'ailleurs on a mesuré ce qu'on
appelle un potentiel électoral or c'est
pas une intention de vatin sait on
demande aux français s'ils pourraient
potentiellement voter pour lui il ya 12
% des français qui nous disent
certainement et puis elle à 15% qui
disent probablement donc il ya un
potentiel pour pour jean luc mélenchon
maintenant il ya des limites vous le
disiez c'est son image et auprès même
des électeurs de gauche à tous les
électeurs plutôt socialiste ou
écologique de ce sensibilité là peuvent
se dire bon bah c'est un vote utile
d'une certaine manière je peux faire
figurer des idées de gauche au second
tour maintenant c'est jean luc mélenchon
et l'image qu'on en a quelqu'un
d'impulsif d'agressif même s'ils
considèrent qu'il est plutôt convaincant
ça un bon tribun il ya une vraie
difficulté et puis son autre difficulté
aussi je termine là dessus c'est son
électorat est plutôt un électorat
abstentionnistes ce sont plutôt des
jeunes des catégories populaires donc il
n'est pas certain que ces électeurs se
déplacent aux urnes le jour du premier
tour donc il ya des vrais des vrais
fragilité dans ce dans cette dynamique
voir les détails des traits d'image dont
vous parlez alex détailler les traits
d'image des baromètres doxa oui dans ce
baromètre en tout cas il n'y a pas une
majorité de français qui est bien trouvé
une qualité à jean luc mélenchon par
exemple 44% le trouve proche des gens
39% le trouve convaincant 36% le trouve
honnête et on commence à baisser
seulement 34% le trouvent sympathique et
la qualité de jean luc mélenchon qui est
la moins plébiscités et bien c'est sa
capacité à diriger le pays seulement 28%
estiment qu'il en serait capable en fait
ce sont plutôt les défauts de jean luc
mélenchon qui font consensus parmi les
français 78% considèrent qu'il est
impulsif 70% le trouve agressif et
politiquement 64% trouve qu'il est
populiste et puis une bonne majorité de
français estime que jean luc mélenchon
et sectaire
mélenchon oui
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il est
quand même au coeur de la du paysage
politique française comme eric zemmour
est persuadé qu eric zemmour c'est pas
du tout quelqu'un non plus dont les
traits de caractère sont appréciés qui
est populaire alors que il est quand
même il a fait une entrée tonitruante
dans le paysage politique donc jean luc
mélenchon c'est vrai qu'il a
il a
il à abîmer son image pendant ce
quinquennat il ya eu l'épisode
judiciaire et puis le problème de
l'arrivée d'un sens c'est qu'il est un
peu insaisissable et à mon avis il a
raté
sa carrière politique il a raté sa
carrière politique pourquoi parceque il
n'a jamais été une figure centrale du
parti socialiste il a quitté parti
socialiste il n'a eu de cesse que de
casser ce parti socialiste là comme s'il
avait une revanche à prendre sur lui et
il a fait une erreur magistrale en 2017
en 2017 alors qu'il avait fait une
élection tout à fait honorable même plus
qu'honorable puisque lille était en très
bonne position à la sortie de ce scrutin
alors que la gauche n'était pas en très
grande forme alors que la droite était
quand même sérieusement abîmée eh bien
il aurait dû être le
père le personnage central de la
recomposition de la gauche or ce qu'il a
à faire il a fait tout le contraire de
marine le pen alors que marine le pen
mis cinq ans à se recentrer lui il sait
d'emblée jeu d'entrée de jeu radicaliser
souvenez vous quand même injuste après
la présidentielle on va marcher sur
l'elysée je vais mettre un million de
personnes sur les champs elysées il n'a
jamais réussi à le faire ça a été un
échec total et la radicalisation de son
discours a été une erreur fondamentale
et ça a été un échec total moralité et
bien il s'est fait doubler par un
mouvement qui s'appelle le mouvement des
gilet jaune et ce qu'il n'a pas réussi à
faire le mouvement du gilet jaune a
réussi à faire
et depuis bas depuis les alors
évidemment peut-être que l'élection
présidentielle me faire mentir et que
comme en 2017 et ben il était prévu à 12
13 et puis il va terminer à 20 ou à 19
j'en sais rien je crois mais je pense
qu'il a quand même une
il a fait une erreur d'analysé à la
sortie du sco table 2017
oui oui c'est fin c'est plus qu'une
erreur d'analysé je pense que c'est son
propre s'est lui même c'est son
caractère qui est revenu au galop et
donc mais à chaque campagne en fait on
constate la même chose il arrive à peu
près à corriger son image sans doute
conseillé par par tous ses proches parce
que il a il a cette forte capacité de
tribun de conviction il est très bon
dans les discours donc c'est une bête de
campagne d'une certaine manière la
campagne comme des traits négatifs
revient en partie maintenant il ya
toujours des reste un que les tous les
adjectifs que que vous donniez tout à
l'heure ils sont largement partagé par
les français alors c'est assez logique
chez sa pâtée en boîte mais ils le sont
aussi chez les sympathisants de la
gauche plus modérés qui pourrait
éventuellement par vote utile dans dans
l' enquête il ya un autre résultat qui
est intéressant c'est on a demandé aux
gens qui nous disent je pourrais
certainement ou probablement voter pour
jean luc mélenchon si c'est un vote
d'adhésion finalement ce parce qu'il
partage vraiment son programme ou bien
c'est plutôt un vote utile et il ya une
majorité qui parle plutôt de vote utile
donc c'est plutôt parce que c'est le
candidat le moins éloigné lors de leur
as de leurs idées et puis parce que
c'est la capacité à faire figurer des
idées de gauche au second tour donc il
faut qu'il réussisse à convaincre cette
partie là de l'électorat qu'il n'est pas
si impulsif si agressif si dangereux
finalement parce que c'est le regard que
portent ces cet électorat sur lui c'est
c'est qui est cet homme finalement s'il
prend de velours un jour qu'est ce que
ça va donner donc c'est vrai il doit
répondre à ces questions et rassurer cet
électorat là s'il veut avoir des chances
de figurer au second tour
2010 est en bois encore il ya personne à
gauche madame diallo n'arrive pas à
émerger
jadot non plus ça c'est le désert quoi
basez c'est lui et lui il en a la
capacité en plus de ce qu'il a cette
force tribunicienne et il a raté chute
j'estime qu'il a raté le coche
oui puisque c'était en garde les
sondages ce sont les deux candidats qui
ont le plus de chances d'aller au second
tour face à emmanuel macron et ce
baromètre analyse leur potentiel
électoral avec cette question vous la
cie tier pourriez vous votez pour ce
candidat est bien 37 % répondent qu'ils
pourraient voter pour marine le pen et
seulement 27% pour jean luc mélenchon
marine le pen a donc un plus gros
potentiel de vote que le candidat de la
france est soumise il ya une bataille
entre jean luc mélenchon et marine le
pen notamment dans l'électorat populaire
oui alors déjà il ya une première
bataille c'est le premier tour c'est les
deux candidats qui potentiellement
puisque boveri pécresse eric zemmour
sont plutôt en baisse donc la tendance
est plutôt à ce que le deuxième et
troisième ce soit marine le pen et jean
luc mélenchon donc il ya une concurrence
là dessus et il ya effectivement une
concurrence aussi sur certain électorat
notamment les catégories populaires où
ils sont finalement en concurrence sur
ces électorats là et peut y avoir un
basculement d'un côté ou de l'autre
alors on parle pas de militants qui sont
très convaincus on parle plutôt d'un
électorat c'est général qui peut être à
la fois tenté par jean luc mélenchon est
à la fois tenté par parraine marine le
pen
nous disait que leur dynamique quand
jean luc mélenchon monter marine le pen
monte aussi puisqu'il y avait une sorte
de réflexion utile à l'extrême droite et
que ça faisait baisser régler pour vous
partager ce conseil oui oui bien sûr moi
je qualifierais pas de d'extrême droite
moi je parlerais de candidat
nationaliste je trouve que c'est extrême
droite
je dirais nationalistes d'un
nationalisme affichée alors qu'est
qu'est vraiment très affirmée chez eric
zemmour beaucoup moins évident chez
marine le pen maintenant d'ailleurs je
trouve
oui oui il ya un réflexe de vote mais si
vous voulez je crois que ce qui est
intéressant c'est pourquoi ils sont
forts et l'un et l'autre enfin fort on
va relativiser les choses mais parce que
leurs pleurs leur propre camp est faible
la droite est dans les dans le fossé et
plus la droite est faible plus marine le
pen risque d'être forte
pareil pour
jean luc machon plus la gauche est
faible puis ils en bénéficient partager
ce constat et des faiblesses de leur
camp c'est évident et bien sûr même si
c'est plus plus contestable pour marine
le pen qui est plus parce que finalement
vous avez emmanuel macron qui est plutôt
du centre-droit les électeurs en tout
cas considère qu'il est un peu plus à
droite qu'à gauche donc valérie pécresse
a plus de mal à exister face à emmanuel
macron ce qui n'est pas le cas des
électeurs de gauche c'est l'un des
candidats gauche et candidat gauche
peuvent parfaitement exister face à
emmanuel macron ce qui n'arrive pas à
faire et est donc marine le pen elle est
plutôt sur un électorat qui aujourd'hui
c'est important le on peut l'appeler
l'extrême droite la droite radicale peu
importe la droite nationaliste peu
importe comment on l'appelle mais c'est
à peu près 30% des électeurs à eux seuls
ces 30% c'est à peu près l'équivalent de
la gauche et le centre fait à peu près
la même chose à 30% donc elle a un
électorat une base électorale assez
colossal elle est contestée par eric
zemmour mais eric zemmour a été sans
doute trop a dit qu'aller à 100 nous
parlait trop des sujets d'identité
d'immigration et pas suffisamment des
sujets économiques le pouvoir d'achat et
donc il a patiné dans cette campagne et
sa hausse s'est finalement arrêté
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt même une baisse
est plutôt aux alentours de 10 ans %
dans les intentions de vote aujourd'hui
m les chaînes parlementaires
la presse régionale sur donc l'image de
jean luc mélenchon
[Musique]